[Music]  no doubt Justin Bieber is one seriously  talented performer but still sometimes  even the best entertainers forget the  lyrics  case in point Bieber's recent attempt to  sing the chorus of deceit though  [Music]  that's beaver Tuesday night at 1oak in  New York City he's featured on the Latin  Smash Hits remix yes he sings in Spanish  alongside Luis FONSI and daddy yankee  [Music]  yeah not exactly the same but one  thing's for sure Bieber Spanish skills  totally won over Fonzie and Yankee if he  did his thing you know he's saying his  verse in English he's saying the course  in Spanish you know that was awesome  yeah nobody was expecting that right  like he's singing in Spanish I think  that what that makes the the ring even  better yes see though  [Music]  you